咱們借得了這麼賺錢 但是我今天準備馬人了
因為我看到了很多20年前的那種似於維持的我
我是希望能夠罷行他們
這樣你才能夠開敲
今天這條視頻可能會有點長
然後我說的稍微賣一點
我一邊思考 然後一邊和大家聊
又要跟大家來回來回那種廢話特別多
我自己的家裡的家裡的顏壁不很好
我上學的說如果家裡不是全班最窮的
也是到數第二窮的
我到了20多歲的時候我才拿到的低通勁
也是幾元巧合 但更重要的是因為我的努力
然後特別辛苦特別努力的
就是工作的有10年 活到10年
然後來賺錢 老生人體 老了一生的貓餅
我到了30多塊到40歲的時候才終於開敲
如果我能夠找明白
這些支持的話 你知道和你真正的理解是不一樣的
我覺得我可以稍作很多萬多
我簡單和大家分享
第一個是納玩耳說的
我很早就提回到了 但納玩耳把它歸解了
於句話叫什麼呢 叫賺錢是於中文 漆能
既然是漆能 你就需要去學習掌握和聯繫的
你好好體會 也就話
比如說我們開車 你戀過吧
你沒戀過車 你沒學過車 你怎麼會開車呢
對吧 比如說你寫字 你說這寫得好看 這個人在寫得好看
你肯定是戀過的 你這個字才能小看
沒有人一上海就 就能把這寫得好看吧
那麼各位有跟你個問題啊
你對錢一無所知 你對錢能理解 根本一點知識的沒有
平時也沒有人跟你討論和交流
你也沒有專門練過
你怎麼可能一上來 或者第一次創業就賺錢呢
你只有可能口 買財票的那種狀態運 各位想像是不這樣的
但是我們很多人都是這個樣子
我有時候再給大家講
怎麼賺錢的一些視頻的時候 我經常能看到這種留言
目明其妙的一個 目的是能給你講怎麼賺錢
你就記住了 他一定是想賺錢
這個認識挺早搞的
各位 好好思考一下 賺錢是一種其能
你是需要更多的理由 結他的
你需要和很多人去討論和交流的
你需要在實操的公眾 不斷的去練習的 就像你開車一樣
如果你越遠去的 越讓離他 你越不可能掌握這項其能
是第一個部分
第二塊的話 就是你能賺多少錢呢 你的下限去就運得奴隸程度
你就拿怕你沒有什麼認知
但是你的下限可以保證得分寶 他覺得呢 去就運得奴隸程度
你的上限去就運得認知 就能這麼多少錢
去就運得認知
那麼這個錢大概有哪些來源呢 各位有四種
第一種的話呢 說實話 我們一般人做不了
但是越往後
其實越適合我們普通人 但是我們先說的第一種
第一種是什麼呢 就是窗心
就是窗心 窗道一個別人需要的東西
比如說敲不散一碰 比如說特斯拉的
比如說馬斯克特斯拉 但是我們大部分做不了 為什麼 因為我們
缺很多人缺少 窗心的這樣的一個習慣和基因
就是我們小的時候 往往是大對體就能得分
你要是有不同的答案
有些時候還要受的答案
你思考要是不是這樣 這種情況下你怎麼能窗心呢
但是好消息是什麼呢 就是你不需要像
喬布斯拉 或者馬斯克特斯拉做那麼大的窗心
你可以改進現有的一些產品做一些小的態度
比如說我今天看一個故事 就是沙拉 這是真實的故事 大家可以查
他原來是一個公司的這個女子 紙兒
但是呢 他喜歡穿白色的故事
穿白色的故事就會有問題
那一樣什麼那個熱就露出來了
他就覺得很不爽 他就找了那種現有的哭話
他把那個腳指頭 腳指前面的腳指的 剪掉
然後從應該造 這樣的話穿起來就會很舒服
他突然就在立個靈感的時候能不能做這樣一間
這樣的一些那一一呢
然後就花了五千塊錢
然後開始做作的一邊然後猜得自己推銷
這公司叫SPANCE
這個目前為這個事實
是因為大幼生就可以查一下這個故事
但是這個創新確實是立我們
普通人有些我們先放一個我們來講第二個 第二個
其實就和我們普通人接近了
但是主要這裏一邊的邏輯是什麼
你去銷售那些已經創銷的
已經被證明的商品 但是你要說得很好
什麼意思呢
就是我們很能做銷售說這個銷售技巧很重要
但是我認為
好的產品更重要 又去對我們普通來說
銷售的有兩種 與總是人待貨用是貨待人
比如說這個商品不知名了
我通過一個明星
我通過一個網紅 把人銷售的人待貨嗎
等另外一種就是貨待人 傻意思呢
就你這個人沒什麼技巧
就是貨品反而會更靠賣
你找那些銷售的比較好的
商品而這個商品也比較好
對吧 然後你就把自己的使用體驗 你真的覺得好
你給別人分享的時候 你其實你不需要那麼高潮的
這個銷售技能
而且你不會遇到各種心理的這種障礙
但是可能就會問一個問題啊
說這個
那人家那麼好賣的東西
還需要你賣嗎
需要
各位 這個世界永遠有認知差
能了解嗎 有一個新鮮來的時候
很多會
會吃底臭的心理
就展開自己原來被提出這個位
好不容易接受了
好不容易接受了 他有缺乏行動
行動以後做到一半的時候 他就退縮了
就這幾項能給你幹掉百分之八十的人
所以這個
你是可以做的
而且呢
很多商品 很多好的銷售好的公司
偉大的公司也不一定是做創造新的人
商品 比如說
這個
楊馬雄
對吧 他生產國書嗎
生產國產品嗎 他不是
金東也不是
但是他通過優化效率
把這個福田給你做得更好
就像斷人評出的
幹為天下後
就這個東西已經很好了 你去銷售這樣的一個商品
但是呢 你可以做到提升
比評的人嗎
比評的人是你的心動力
認知差
有信息差 認知差 行動差
和競爭差
銷售那些已經做得比較好的商品
然後呢
你可能會更容易獲得頂待
什麼時候的第二個部分
第三個部分是什麼呢
就是任用工具關係
這個工具關係表面上我們好像能理解
但注意了這個特別社會普通人
而且這裡沒有個其他的機會
這個工具關係的話早期我們才有什麼呢
就是這個地方有那地方沒有
我完成一些班運
可能像導致也一樣
比如說我們
泰國的流連運到我們北京來吃 對不對
完成這樣一個工具關係
但是現在有這種更新的工具關係
而且現在就是機會
我舉個例子 今天我看一條一個故事
然後把整個全部追述了一遍
這個人的話就要
Buckley
不來課 不來課
這個大學畢業以後的話呢
他是沒工作
他也沒好學
人家都上工作 他沒工作
半到四季父母家裡 夠丟人吧
然後管他哥哥有錢話
後來這個們覺得不好意思
等半的時候我要
自己當錢
我今天要追到半 萬萬錢
這怎麼可能
後來怎麼做呢
他花時間去學些AI
AI的使用AI的變成
用了一年半的時間做了生活人家
每一款人家一年
都能獲得幾百萬美金
這真實啊 以我把那個產品給你貼出來
第一款產品幹嘛呢
是做了一個約會的
約會的說發休息 不知道怎麼會休息
不知道怎麼發休息
的準備做得這麼一款產品
我相信我之前有朋友叫小藝
做AI女友的這個產品
第二款產品
第一個產品我就不介紹了
因為我這個沒什麼經理
第二個產品是什麼 第二個產品就這樣了
我覺得和第一個產品是
一般相重的 幹嘛呢
就是
你拍個照
拍完照以後
然後這個AI給你打分
我們現在有吧
但是我告訴你
他又下一個
告訴你
你可以這麼感應的發行
可以用這個發行
什麼什麼地方可以做
然後你的這個眼睛就可以帶一個什麼
有什麼什麼地方可以做
你可以留個胡子等等等等
還有這麼一個產品就拍個照
他給你各種感到建議
這一款AI產品
一年現在下來也幾萬美金
他的第三款產品就和我特別的
我聽完了以後
第一個想法就是為什麼我沒有想到
幹嘛呢
那我以前剪費啊
現在說我自己啊 我以前剪費
你剪費又用的話就控制卡路里嘛
是不是
那時候就是
看什麼東西都採查
這個
請在卡里德上
不過他在卡里德
卡路里德上能吃多少
我今天不要操作卡路里對不對
那時候還有去查一個
就很不方便
那時候就想要一拍不就行了嗎
但是我跟你講
他就做一款產品
一拍照你吃什麼拍一拍照
把自己領順的卡路里來
你今天還有多少的旅持
我當然看了那款產品的時候
我發現對什麼我沒做
忘了
隨時記錄自己的需求啊
記錄自己的想法是非常非常重要的
那這個產品為什麼
它為什麼能夠在
很多那時間內
有一個5月有名人
然後線學變成
然後一年可以
轉幾百萬呢
其實這裡沒有兩個有個機會
第一個機會是什麼呢
第一個就是AI
可以
大量的降低我的成本
吸高我們的效率
第二
就是
火量可以幫你獲得大量用
你看以前你做一個能用加肥的那個產品
算卡路的產品
你還有點麻煩
但現在以為AI就特別容易
那對你來說有什麼好處呢
我給大家講的小例子
記錄這個世界永遠有
吸吸差
永遠有
人之差
那些跟你講賺錢的人都講賺你錢
你想想
就這種人很多的
行動力也不夠的對吧
一定有的
好
各位
第4個他是免費的
你是可以把他下個海的
開完的
對吧
然後的話呢我告訴你
有些地方他不需要那麼不小版學的
不需要那麼慶準
就夠用了
我舉個例子啊
比如說一些蔡銀公司
你可以把這些蔡銀的數據
未可以
這個大貓行
讓這個大貓行幫你分析
你們講什麼蔡貓的好啊成本怎麼樣啊
用戶最喜歡什麼人的口味啊
喜歡這些東西都可以
都可以算出來吧
是否可以優化你的成本
你說是可以利用這些模型
幫你做一些銀銀銀銀銀銀銀銀
我只舉個例子啊簡單的這個蔡銀公司
但是會被傳統行業裡面
你都可以用本地不屬的方式
幫這些傳統行業改進一下
那很多人說
人家也會這個的我告訴你
不會的
這個世界永遠有
信息差
認知差
行動差
和行動差
你去感受一下這是機會
等第三個
有四個的話呢
其實我已經說過不說被安排很久沒當回事
就是干擾
這個實在是我干擾的
我們以前的干擾是什麼人的一港擾
我對我開公司
我任用更何時的人把他放在不同的位置
變成
一份系統
然後這個系統可以存在更高的價值
這樣我打法不工作我也可以賺錢
我們以前為什麼那麼多開公司
就這個原因
你公司是多少人呢
來吧
很難得公司打小
但是現在不是吧
現在有些時候一個人就可以創造很多
公司的例子是這樣的吧
還有什麼呢軟件啊
軟件
有你睡覺的時候軟件也可以幫你搞定機械兒也可以幫你搞定
這邊還有什麼就是我說過不說被安排了
自媒體
我前面給大家講過很多很多寫作的事為什麼
你寫了一個東西
你可以獲得打的用
你可以一堆多
而你做任何事你不都需要用戶嗎
所以寫作自媒體是一個非常有名的進行
你畢竟學很多不會不會你可以戀愛啊
對吧你要學會
利用港版
今天就掉了這麼多吧
就是你需要對錢有
足夠的人質我突然想
想起好多人的那個留言啊
我想起到二十多年前的我
有一個朋友
然後他家裡聽很有錢
要給我介紹很多有錢的朋友
我當時就覺得
而是我當時特別純特別用之我說了那麼有啊
這就是我說的啊
我看不起那些有錢人
還有一點高的樣子
還有
很問我
你為什麼看不起有錢人呢
跟歷史什麼樣
虛榮
用錢的話說什麼呢
所以又菜
然後又什麼
對吧
就說想到這時候就看到的我看到很多人留言就想起的
二十多年前的我